[Applause]
good morning and welcome to well it says
here's Sunny Essex
it was sunny when I left home it's
slightly overcast and I think there's
winds expected later today but that's
enough of the weather forecast so I'm
really proud to welcome you all here for
the launch of Labor of the next Labor
government's mission to make the NHS fit
for the future
everyone in this room will owe a debt of
gratitude to the NHS for a moment in
their lives whether it's the birth of a
child
a parent who was cared for or a life
saved I was diagnosed with kidney cancer
at the age of 38. and from the point I
received the diagnosis I felt a
Rolls-Royce machine kick into gear
I was treated by a world leading surgeon
assisted by a robot
and of all the things going through my
mind during that period for one thing I
never had to worry about was the bill
but I also saw an NHS that is struggling
brilliant staff
but overworked under-resourced
and burnt out
saw how the NHS doesn't provide the
level of at-home care that patients
deserve
and the truth is I was lucky
I went into hospital because I had a
kidney stone
and if it wasn't for that who knows how
much longer it would have been before my
cancer was discovered
and there are far too many people in
this country who aren't as lucky as I
was whose conditions are not spotted
until it's too late
too many lives are needlessly lost
because the NHS doesn't get there early
enough
that is the change the NHS is crying out
for early diagnosis early intervention
and preventing ill health in the first
place and that is the change that a
labor government will bring about
and if we're serious about turning the
NHS around from the worst crisis in its
history to make it fit for the future if
we're serious about giving everyone the
opportunity to live healthier longer
lives it requires cross-government work
it requires partnership between the
state the private sector and Civil
Society
and that will only happen with strong
leadership from the top
today kierstama is setting out a hugely
ambitious plan not just to get the NHS
back to where it was with the last Labor
government but to achieve things that
have never before been possible
compare that with Rishi sunax
short-termism and lack of ambition for
our country
so unambitious that if next month
but a full 7.3 million to 7.2 million we
would no doubt see the Prime Minister
rushing onto the Airways to declare
Victory faster than suela bravaman
hurtling down a Motorway
and that's just one of the many
differences between the kind of prime
minister that kierstama will be and the
abysmal leadership the conservative
party has inflicted on Britain in recent
years
having spent his life dedicated to
Public Service fairness and Justice care
knows better than anyone the number of
lives that can be turned around and
saved by a nurse a GP a teacher a social
worker a care worker
the missions here is setting for the
next Labor government are the priorities
of the British people
and he will be a prime minister who
pulls every lever available to achieve
them and gets every Department working
together to build a healthier Nation
and if you think
that what labor is promising today is
too ambitious if you think it cannot be
done
I would gently remind you that you would
have said the same thing in 2019 when
Pierce said that labor could win the
next general election
and since then I have seen inkir a
leader who focuses relentlessly on the
job at hand who never gets distracted by
the noise is off and is ambitious for
Britain so just as he has turned around
the labor party from its worst defeat
since 1935 to a party that is ready to
serve the country once more he will turn
around the NHS from the biggest crisis
in its history and make it fit for the
future so please give a warm welcome to
the leader of the labor party our next
prime minister kierstama
and I didn't think
[Applause]
thank you
thank you Wes thank you all for being
here it is fantastic to be in Braintree
um I've got very fond memories of this
part of the world because 16 happy years
ago I got married just down the road in
the fence so that's why it's got this
special place in my heart and almost as
good as that this is where two weeks ago
at the local elections the labor party
was back on the march in Essex
but today I'm here to speak about
something that's fundamental to the
labor party fundamental to our purpose
of working people
the NHS
just look at it
the eight o'clock scramble
the appointments missed opportunities
missed to spot the pain that turned out
to be a tumor patients who want to go
home are well enough to go home but who
have to stay in hospital for months
waiting for a care package
day long waits in a e
record numbers off work sick
people pulling their own teeth out
seven million on waiting waiting waiting
lists
and ambulances for heart attacks and
stroke victims that don't come on time
just think about that for a second
ambulances that don't come
can any of you imagine losing someone in
that way
I can't I can't and and I mean that in
every sense
I can't imagine it it shouldn't be
possible in our country but it is
a cruel Lottery of who lives and who
dies that the NHS was founded to stop
and until now until this point for 75
years it has
it's one of the greatest privileges of
being born in Britain certainly for all
of my life
the knowledge that if you get ill
if you have a serious accident
you'll get the care that you need
whatever your circumstances
not every country has a system like that
and the insecurity the fear without it
is huge
Knight Bevin the labor Health secretary
who created the NHS put it best
he said
illness is neither an Indulgence for
which people have to pay
nor an offense for which they should be
penalized
that's what we believe
and it's under threat I mean it
I don't think the NHS survives five more
years of Tory government
and people say oh well we've heard this
before the labor party is always saying
it's time to save the NHS
but I say
look squarely in the eyes of the people
who work in the NHS who serve the NHS
and ask them
speak to the working people who use the
NHS who depend on the NHS who need the
NHS
what do they say
and go to the people who believe in the
NHS love the NHS but have been forced to
buy the care they need from the private
sector listen to them
no at the next election the NHS is on
the line the conservative party that's
brought it to its knees will put it in
the ground
but mark my words
if all we do in the labor party is to
place the NHS on a pedestal and leave it
there
that's not good enough either
we've got to fix the fundamentals
renew its purpose make it fit for the
future
that's what this mission is about a new
direction for the NHS
to say to the British people vote labor
problem solved would be an insult to
everyone's intelligence
patients can see how deep the problems
go
my Approach is different
it starts with the cause
the central project
how do we serve working people
and then it asks what do we value what
do we conserve cherish and protect
the answer
a public and Universal Health System
free at the point of use paid for by
General taxation the NHS
but Zenith asks what do we need to
change
what are the challenges the
opportunities how can we save lives
improve lives provide more dignity
Innovation where can it be found people
how do we unlock their purpose
technology how do we make it work for us
and when you've asked those searching
questions you turn back you roll up your
sleeves or you face reality
and the reality is this
the NHS is not sustainable unless we
make serious deep long-term changes
that's my politics reform for Renewal
National missions for the common good
and NHS fit for the future
some people will tell you it's purely a
question of money
and money is a part of it I don't deny
that like any opposition we will set out
our plans before the election unlike any
incoming government we will make
decisions based on a full appreciation
of the reality the state of our NHS and
our public finances
but what's more important now I really
believe this is to show our recipe for
reform
to put forward a vision of a renewed NHS
that can make the most of the money we
invest in it
I've run a public service I know that
money makes a difference
but it only gets you so far
you can't look at the problems now and
tell me it's just about money
that's not serious
you can't ignore the fact the world has
changed that's denying the evidence
before our eyes
the British people are living longer
life expectancy in 1948 was 68. today
it's over 81. that is a good thing
but it brings new challenges
the nature of disease is different
instead of urgent and acute hospital
care
now it's more about managing chronic
long-term conditions
The Wonder of science has taught us with
ever increasing Clarity that our health
depends on how we live
mental health has stepped out of the
shadows and thank goodness
and with artificial intelligence with
personalized medicine with new vaccines
we stand on the cusp of a revolution
that could transform health care for the
better
my message today is this
Science and Technology are the game
changers this is the prize this is what
it gives us an NHS where prevention
comes first where care is closer to home
where patients have more control
so
to everyone working in the NHS today
serving on the front line
I say
thank you
without you there would be no light at
the end of the tunnel
but I also say
the walk towards that light will be hard
will feel challenging difficult
but do not doubt it's essential and that
the reward for reform will be worth it
and look don't doubt this either the
Taurus will never deliver this
they voted against the NHS right at the
start and more than once
and while they've come to accept it as
part of the political furniture
in their heart of hearts they don't
believe in its Central promise for them
it's a cost not a Cause
and from that mindset Springs The Well
of their neglect the poverty of their
ambition the sticking plaster crisis
management impulse that never sees the
opportunities never addresses the long
term
it's it's not that they don't care
it's that they're priorities their
ideology it takes them somewhere else
200 billion pounds a year that doesn't
square with their small state vision of
Britain and that's why we have familiar
problems every year for the last 13
years we've had a winter crisis and
every year in about February or March
we do just enough to keep the NHS going
we breathe a bit in the summer and then
we go into the next NHS crisis the next
winter the only difference being it's
worse than the one that went before
they know what's even worse than that
the tourists underestimate the NHS
underestimate the bond between people
and service
underestimate what you can do with a
mission
that yes people go to work in EHS for a
wage of course they do
but of also because they believe in
something
this is how we go beyond the sticking
plaster mindset how we solve the crisis
and tackle the long-term challenges
I want an NHS back on its feet of course
I do
but I also want an NHS that's fit for
the future
and that requires a partnership
between people and service
that builds on what is distinctive about
the NHS as a health system
now
protect the NHS was the pandemic slogan
and we did
and in turn
it predict it protected us
so have no doubt this mission is a cause
but it's a cause that can only succeed
if we embrace the need for reform
so Labor's National mission on health
to build an NHS fit for the future
and as with all our missions we set that
Direction with clear measurable goals
goal one the next Labor government will
deliver an NHS that is there when you
need it
ambulances seven minutes for Cardiac
Arrest A E back to the four-hour Target
gp's the highest satisfaction levels on
record waiting lists Down plan treatment
within 18 weeks no backsliding no
excuses we will meet these standards
again we will get the NHS back on its
feet
dull two
we will improve healthy life expectancy
for all and we'll halve the inequality
gap between different regions of England
and let me explain what that means
it means we will restart a trend Britain
has come to take for granted that to be
blunt we should take for granted
a sign of progress that generation after
generation the people of this country
are living healthier lives happier lives
and longer lives
the tourists have reversed that
that's their legacy
and look by focusing on health
inequalities we can make Britain fairer
as well
did you know
black women are four times more likely
to die whilst having a baby than white
women
in my constituency a girl born in
Highgate Hill will live 10 years longer
than a girl born in summers town
that is three miles away
my labor party won't stand by and let
that happen we've got to root these
inequalities out
and to achieve this we must Zone in on
our biggest killers
three killers which we know are
demanding questions of our health care
System
one cardiovascular diseases heart
attacks and strokes we'll get them down
by a quarter within a decade
two
cancer
we will make sure 75 percent of all
cancer is diagnosed at stage one or two
let me tell you what that means the
difference it will make
the survival rate for cancer at stage
one and two is 81 percent
but at stage three and four it's just 26
percent
what a difference that would make
and finally
killer three
suicide
last year I went to an event organized
by the band New Order
and they asked me for obvious reasons
given their history
did I know anyone
that's died in that way
I have to admit it took me a back I've
never been asked that certainly not in
public before
but you know
I didn't have to think that long
I do
more than one in fact
three friends
and if I asked everyone in this room
the same question
I guess you wouldn't have to think about
it for long either
suicide is the biggest killer of young
lives in this country
the biggest killer
that statistic should haunt us
and the rate is going up
our mission must be and will be to get
it down
so there's no time to do that this
Mission starts with people
that's at the height of the classes
right now that's why we've committed to
the biggest expansion of NHS training in
its history
all nurses doctors midwives and health
visitors all fully funded by removing
the non-dom tax status
it's why we'll leave no stone unturned
when it comes to finding new ways to cut
waiting lists labor has done it before
and will do it again
imagine that you're waiting for a knee
operation
and the waiting list isn't going down at
your local hospital
but in the trust next door they have a
specialist Orthopedic Center and things
are moving much more quickly
I say you should be able to go there
instead
I say there shouldn't be a separate
waiting list at this Hospital a separate
waiting list at that hospital hospitals
should work together
so I can announce today to cut waiting
lists more quickly patients should be
able to visit nearby hospitals when
faster treatment is available and labor
will give them that choice
and that's only the beginning
as I keep saying we've got to go beyond
the sticking plaster approach
I talked earlier about the light at the
end of the tunnel
the reward for reform
we've got to hold on to that and there
are grounds to be optimistic
but it will require three shifts shifts
which must place at the heart of
everything we do on health
shift one
we must move care away from hospitals
and closer to the community
the NHS must become a Neighborhood
Health Service
I'll put it bluntly at the moment we
aren't good enough at treating people
early in the community
we leave it to hospitals and quite often
that's too late
and if we change this it will save lives
and money
that's why we're going to improve GP
access ND 8am scramble
we'll trade more GPS but we'll also make
the future of general practice more
sustainable
as the contractor model declines in some
communities we won't let patients go
without the care that they need
so we'll bring fragmented Services
together and make sure salary GP serve
all communities
and we'll modernize the appointment
system
for those who want real continuity of
care
will bring back the family doctor that's
what people with long-term conditions
need
but for those who just want a quick
appointment at their convenience who
want a digital consultation will give
those patients a different route
seriously it can't be Beyond us to offer
different options for different people
we've just got to roll up our sleeves
and get it done
and one more thing we've got to fix the
backdoor problem
we can't have hospitals blocked up by
patients who are desperate to go home
and ready to be discharged
so we'll make good on the integration of
Health and Social care
backing successful models like the
center at Bromley by Beau
where in one place they bring together
doctors nurses physiotherapists social
carers to provide joined up care in the
community keeping people out of Hospital
and look we will recruit and retain more
carers with a fair pay agreement
this is fundamental
it's about who and what we respect
it's about better standards at work
about dignity more progression more
training more rights and yes about pay a
fair deal for our carers that's what
people clapped for
shift to we must move from a mindset
that views Health as all about sickness
to one where we put prevention first
right across Society
so we'll take bold action where early
intervention can make a huge difference
on Mental Health
and make no mistake we intend to
revolutionize mental health treatment in
this country
8 500 new mental health professionals
specialist access in every school
guaranteed treatment inside four weeks
for anyone who needs it
and look the mission we're launching
today isn't just an NHS mission
it's a Health Mission
when we talk about a new deal for
working people on employment rights
about good work for all that's a health
policy
when we say We'll provide breakfast
clubs with healthy food for all primary
school children that's a health policy
when we commit to restoring a decent
home standard to regulating the water
industry to a new Clean Air Act they're
all Health policies
and when I say we will take on the
social media companies who push
dangerous misogyny on our children
I am saying very clearly to those who
profit from harming our children no
not in Britain
and today we go further on that
we will change advertising rules and we
will make sure that products which are
harmful to our children's health vaping
junk food sugary snacks cannot be
advertised to our children no
not in Britain
shift three technology
a revolution that will accelerate the
first two shifts and Herald a different
kind of Health Care
a move from an analog to a digital NHS a
tomorrow service not just a today
service
and my words this can be
transformational
the route to the NHS offering shorter
waiting times better treatment early
diagnosis and meaningful prevention
Britain leaves the world in science and
technology we can make this happen this
is the game changer the light at the end
of the tunnel this is what will make the
NHS fit for the future
I'll give an example
33 million people downloaded the NHS app
during the pandemic and it's a good app
but that extraordinary opportunity
it's been wasted
labor would take the app and Innovations
like it
we would deepen them expand them and put
them in the hands of patients
and use them to transform our
relationship with the NHS
get this right and it means moving to a
fully digital patient records never
again handwritten notes getting lost
it means booked appointments appropriate
self-referral routes remind us to get
checkups and screening the latest
guidance on treatment
patients in control of their own data
choosing how it's used and how it's
shared
this will get rid of a divide between
those confident to speak up for
themselves
and those who can't
and look if we make sure everyone is
supported
then we can take people on this journey
and it will mean people can get better
choices we'll get faster care can manage
their own health
in truth it's about politicians catching
up with the public and the NHS catching
up with the revolution that's already
happened in the rest of our lives
and it doesn't stop there
technology provides more choice and
Powerful patients but it also saves
lives
take artificial intelligence
AI will change the nature of Health Care
and Britain is good at AI
I'll give an example
lung cancer is the number one cause of
cancer-related deaths in the UK
274 000 patients waiting for 11 days or
more to hear back from the scan
which could tell them if they have
cancer
AI can reduce workload and raise
productivity but here's the real thing
when used properly by a radiologist
it can reduce missed lung cancer
diagnosis by 60 percent
and because it's quicker
because it's more accurate the lives it
could save through early diagnosis are
countless
but to make this happen innovators need
one route into the NHS not many
incentives to innovate throughout the
system
fewer barriers to adoption fewer hurdles
to clear less bureaucracy more clinical
trials and a government that uses its
full power to back our world-leading
life sciences
and look when you add this all together
the sum total of these three shifts
what you get is a plan a plan for a
future NHS that protects what is
precious and Embraces what is possible
from everyone waiting stuck on the call
at 8am
to a primary care system that offers
different choices for different needs
from long Waits at a e to hospitals that
carry a lighter load because more care
is in the community
an NHS where technology gives patients
more responsibility and professionals
more time
where we diagnose disease earlier
screen people in supermarkets libraries
Leisure centers communities
where we can save lives because Health
Care is closer to lives
and above all where the whole of society
contributes to the mission of healthier
happier longer lives
that's an ambition we can rally around a
goal that can lift the anxiety the pain
the fear faced by millions of families
across the country and replace it with
the hope of a renewed NHS
in place of fear that's what night Devin
my Bevin called his book
and if people want to call me dewey-eyed
want to say I'm a romantic about the
values of the NHS
I plead guilty
the NHS has played an enormous role in
my life
my mum was a nurse
proud nurse too
but she was also severely ill for most
of her life with a rare condition
called Still's disease
at the age of 11
she was told two things
one she would be in a wheelchair by her
twenties
two that she should forget about having
kids
now that diagnosis didn't reckon with my
mum's determination and courage
but it also didn't reckon with the NHS
a doctor at guys Hospital in London
refused to give up
he found an experimental treatment for
this 11 year old girl
and the rest as they say
is history
honestly lots of people say they owe the
NHS everything and I'm definitely one of
them
but that's just the point
mum's story isn't special
behind every single door in this country
there is a family who will have their
own version
this is who we are the NHS belongs to
everyone
the foundation for the comfort security
health of working people
for 75 years an Ever present in our
story family and Nation
my message today is simple
with labor the story continues we have a
plan
and what the patience of the future to
remember this moment remember the
changes we'll make together
that's our mission
we will fight for the NHS we will fix
the NHS we will reform the NHS old
values New Opportunities technology and
science convenience and control renewal
not decline an NHS not just off its
knees but running confidently towards
the future thank you very much
thank you
thank you very much
we're going to take some questions
starting with the media my list tells me
that Helen cap from the BBC is first
Helen
you set out some wide-ranging reforms
but you have said that money does play A
Part would you expect under labor that
overall more money would be going into
the NHS well look money is important but
it's not all about money and what I'm
sending out today is that change and
reform plays a hugely important part and
what I said about technology is an
important part of that technology can be
the revolution technology can do what
money can't do so I accept that money is
part of the solution but change in
reform is hugely important the game
changer is technology is about what we
can do in the future that we can't do
now and that is why this mission is not
just about getting the NHS up myself its
knees my wife says on its face and
getting it standing up again but
actually creating an HS that's fit for
the future and that means harnessing
that technology and that change thank
you very much Helen let me find my list
I've got Liz Liz
hi Liz
hello Liz from Sky News uh just to
follow up on that it does seem like
you're trying to sort of Kick this issue
of money into the long grass a little
bit how do you expect the public to
trust you with the public finances if
you're not prepared to say quite
straightforwardly these are our plans
this is how much they will cost and this
is how we will pay for them if you don't
mind just very quickly on strikes and
striking workers some of them will be
watching this speech thinking oh you're
going to bring loads of new staff into
the NHS but you won't say how much
you're going to pay them
and you won't stand with them on the
picket lines these are the people that
you want to deliver your plans do you
have anything new to say to them today
well Liz look first of all let's just um
call a spade a spade where we've made a
proposal about the change we're going to
bring we've said how it's going to be
funded so this challenge you put to me
that we've not said where the money's
coming from it's just wrong actually are
we going to have the biggest increase in
training for the NHS that it's ever had
in its history yes are we going to pay
for that by abolishing the non-dom tax
status yes are we going to have 8 500
more mental health advisors in our
communities yes are we going to pay for
it by closing the tax loophole for
private Equity yes so what we've been
careful to do is to say where we're
making changes what the change will be
and how we will pay for it but we have
to I think see that the change that can
be brought around through technology and
digital working data AI is going to be
trying transformational of course I know
that we've got to put more money in and
we've got to grow the economy but you
know what we're putting on the table is
the change that the NHS needs for the
future and as for the staff look I know
NHS staff pretty well my wife is one of
them
um so I get a diet a daily readout of
what is uppermost in their mind they
want to know they're fully supportive
they want to know they're they're
respected they want to know there's a
plan for the future because the one
thing that I've been struck by recently
is the number of people who are not just
worrying about appointments about
waiting lists about a e
under this government 13 years of
failure but now worried about whether
the NHS will continue to exist we've not
been in that place before and these
staff share that and when we say to them
we're going to have the biggest training
regime the NHS has ever had that the
Cavalry is coming that is very very
welcome to the staff who desperately
desperately need it thank you Liz at
shehab from ITV
you talk about all these reforms you
talk about new technology that you want
to see introduced into the NHS but all
of that will cost money is there an
estimate of how much exactly this is
going to cost and how quickly can you
implement it and a second question if I
may you've spoken about NHS staff we
know that morale is particularly low at
the moment there are many who feel
they're overworked and underpaid how do
you bring them along with you on this
process of reforming change if you're
not going to pay them more
um look on cost we have set out the
costing for our specific proposals in
terms what it will cost where we will
get the money from
technology research development they
will be the game changers of the future
and reduce costs if we go to a
preventative model it will make a huge
difference take cancer diagnosis it's
not just obviously better for patients
to be diagnosed earlier because you
heard the statistics about survival
rates it's also a reduction of cost
across the NHS merging waiting lists so
that you don't have to just wait for one
Hospital you go to different hospitals
will reduce the cost so you know I do
understand the challenge that you are
all putting to me but I have run a
public service I do know the stresses
and strained
public service but I also know having
run a public service for five years that
it's not all about cost the change in
reform is critically important and you
know if we just put more money in the
top of our Public Services we will get a
better outcome but we won't get a
materially better outcome unless we
change and reform that was my my lesson
from running a public service for five
years thank you shehab um Chloe from the
eye
you've announced plans for what you
describe as an ambitious reform of
health care but there's been little to
no detail about what you would do about
social care is that no longer a priority
and if it is when are we going to hear
about these plans yeah look it is a
priority because I think everybody
understands that
um the back door to the NHS Hospital
crisis is getting people out of care
into the community and that social care
is a big part of that answer what we
have set out on social care in clear
terms
is a plan for the staff for those who
work in the care sector and declare an
interest my sister is a care worker so I
know the sector pretty well there are
over a hundred thousand vacancies and we
have to fix that problem and I think the
only way we can fix that problem is by
having a framework for staff within
social care so that they have Fair pay
agreements so they have dignity and
respect so they can progress through on
a clear careers path which isn't there
at the moment I think it's one in three
people leaving social care are going
into the NHS and they're doing that
because there there's a better chance of
progression than there is in Social care
we've got to fix that I think we can
look at the roles that social care
workers can do the sorts of tasks that
they can do all of that is a big part of
what we need to do on social care and we
also I think need to have as a clear
principle a sort of home first principle
so that it starts with what can be
supported at home rather than simply
assuming that that can't be provided and
we've got to go elsewhere thank you
Chloe Sam from the Sun
thanks
um would you do anything to reform the
way that you decide how NHS staff are
paid the Royal College of Nursing is
still not happy with their pay offer so
what would you do about that going
forward and would you give a pay rise to
Consultants earning six figure salaries
um look on the structure of negotiations
um we haven't focused on that to be
frank because what I've set out today is
what we need to do to make sure the NHS
is fit for the future so we know that
you know a fair pay agreement Fair pay
isn't an essential part of that and I
would you know I think it was Saturday
just gone
this government has lasted as long as
the last Labor government and that gives
us a really good opportunity to compare
and contrast because under the last
Labor government nurses were paid fairly
there wasn't a national strike waiting
lists were down and satisfaction was at
an a record high compare that with what
we've got now where nobody really
quarrels with the proposition that after
13 years of failure the NHS is on its
knees the only debate we're having is it
on its knees or is it on its face that
is a shocking shocking Legacy thank you
Sam Aubry from the guardian
one of the main targets that you've set
out this morning is to reduce deaths
from heart disease by quarter in 10
years this morning on the radio you were
asked directly and said you wouldn't
support levying a salt or sugar tax
during the cost of living crisis but
when food prices return to normal levels
do you rule out full stop
um Barbara the the focus that we put
today is very clearly on Advertising
this is something that government toyed
with and then moved away from I think
that showed a fundamental weakness in
their approach an unseriousness about
tackling the issues that really matter
what I don't want to do in a cost of
living crisis is to add to the burden of
food cost for families that are
struggling so that's why I've been very
clear about where the focus is today why
we're focusing on advertising and this
can be done very simply and very easily
we'll make a material difference to
predominantly the children and young
people involved into their health but
also have a significant effect on the
NHS itself
um Nick I think the Health Service
Journal
Nick hi I'm Nick Cantina from the Health
Service Channel
um you've set out the plans for
improving performance in the NHS but
under Blair one of the key centers of
that was strong NHS management
um in terms of where do you go forward
from here do you think that we need more
managers just as men just as much as we
need doctors and nurses to get the NHS
back to where it is and a very quick
second question the capital program set
up by the government it do you plan to
carry that on to the new hospitals
program under labor
thank you thank you very much on the
question of
um the staff the workforce of the NHS
my message is clear first thank you
you are the light at the end of the
tunnel and we wouldn't have it without
you
um secondly there's got to be changed
and everybody will have to step up so I
don't think it's a question of
distinguishing I actually think that
um most of the reforms that we want to
carry out will be front line it'll be at
that prevention stage the diagnosis
stage and so it'll be very Frontline LED
but you know everybody across the NHS in
order to sustain the NHS we'll have to
be part of that change and reform on new
hospitals look I mean it's hard to say
we'll continue a plan which isn't really
a plan because these 40 hospitals are
pretty mythical
um but look I don't dispute that
um you know infrastructure and
structures are hugely important in all
of this everybody everywhere will have a
story of hospitals that
um you know have all sorts of
difficulties because they've not been
properly maintained and of course we
will have we will inherit that and we
will have to deal with that I do think
our argument that the burden on
hospitals should be lightened with more
care in the community is hugely
important to this because you know at
the moment there's
earlier stepping stone between the local
GP and going to a hospital and we have
to close that Gap so yes it's a problem
we will inherit no I don't think the
government's got a real plan it was
another thing that was said but will not
be done we will inherit that of course
but our plan goes beyond that question
into the way care will be provided under
a future model to make the NHS not
something that we just reflect on with
pride but actually is there for the next
75 years in the way it's been there for
the last 75. thank you Nick I've got
Sophie from the mirror
from the mirror so you mentioned in your
speech about black women being four
times more likely to die during
childbirth we obviously see these Health
inequalities across the board with staff
too with minority ethnic doctors being
less likely to get specialist NHS
training would you say that the Health
Service is institutionally racist you
also say that you'll root out these
inequalities but can you say actually
how you'll do that uh yeah look I'm not
here to denigrate the Health Service to
naturally
um my point was really to highlight the
inequalities and I I think that
statistic about black women dying
um you know when having a baby is is
very arresting I think nobody can listen
to that and not have instilled in them a
real sense that things have got to
change so wherever it is there's got to
change but inequality is a big part of
the Health Challenge and I don't think
it's possible to solve the Health
Challenge if we don't tackle at the same
time the inequality challenge so thank
you very much Sophie Nick from the
telegraph
thank you to um to come back to the
money if I may you've said the NHS is
underfunded and that you are going to
put more money in health spending is a
proportion of government spending has
risen very rapidly over the last couple
of decades it's now at about 22 percent
and that has obviously come by spending
Less proportionally in other areas
do you think that number's too low and
how high would you be prepared to see
that go 25 30 and on the same theme you
know you've made sort of great play of
balancing the books so when you do come
up with proposals in the future for how
you're going to pay with all this will
you be straight that it's going to be
either tax Rises or spending cuts in
other areas uh Nick firstly on the money
that's already going into the NHS
it needs to be used as effectively and
efficiently as we can and among my
frustrations with the annual NHS winter
crisis
is that the sticking plaster the bit
that comes in January February comes
with a huge price usually too late to
make it as effective as it could be and
therefore
simply the using the money that's going
in more effectively will make a huge
difference there are plenty of other
examples when it comes to early
diagnosis screening preventative
measures
Etc on your challenge as will we set out
in terms what we will spend and where
we'll get the money from then yes as you
will have seen there's a pattern here
under labor which is where we say we're
going to do something we set out what
it's going to do and then we say where
the money will come from we will
continue in that vein but I can't
emphasize enough that
simply believing that everything is
about money and not about change and
reform I think is to look at this in the
wrong way I think that change in reform
technology
AI these are going to transform
Healthcare in the future and reduce the
cost along the way and we've got to
approach the next 75 years the next
generation of healthcare with that very
firmly in mind thank you Nick I've got
Russell from Anglia Russell Hi there
yeah I appreciate you've touched on
infrastructure a little there but you've
come here to the east of England to
outline your plans and your vision for
the NHS the east of England has many uh
NHS buildings which have reached the end
of their life including the hospital in
King's Lynn where are 3 000 props
holding up the roof we've got crumbling
roofs at the West Suffolk Hospital in
berries and Edmonds it is your ambition
to keep people out of hospital but many
will still end up there how much have
you factored in the cost of renewing the
NHS estate in your plans and will that
involve public private Finance
initiatives or are you trying to avoid
locking hospitals into those uh Russell
firstly let me acknowledge the premise
of your question which is the that the
east of England has real challenges when
it comes to hospitals also I think in
terms of GP accessibility in some parts
of the east of England so there's a real
challenge here and yes of course we've
got to deal with the infrastructure the
state of our hospitals is unacceptable
in the east of England or anywhere
across England so we will have to deal
with that my speech our plans today
are or include the future of healthcare
generally so you know will we have to
deal with the terrible Legacy that we
will inherit if we're privileged enough
to come into power yes we will will we
have to fix the problems yes we will I
don't shy away from that but if all we
aspire to do as an incoming labor
government is to fix the problems and
put the NHS back where it was before 13
years of failure then I don't think
that's ambitious enough which is why
we've gone way beyond that today thank
you Russell and I think we've got Ben
from BBC look East
from the BBC in the East um change your
tank slightly you said you came to
Braintree because labor was on the march
in Essex but in Harlem the party went
backwards that's where in our region you
had been bullish about taking Great
Yarmouth Council but failed to do that
and I
local authorities the greens are now the
biggest
why do you think labor underperformed at
the local elections earlier this month
and how much responsibility do you take
for that well Ben thank you very much
for that challenge I think you put a
version of that challenge to me last
year after local elections as well and
quite right to what I would say is this
um three years and a couple of months
ago I took over as leader of the labor
party and as Wes was saying in his
introductory remarks that was a labor
party that just lost an election the
worst loss we'd had since 1935. many
people thought it was impossible to go
from there to even talking about a labor
majority government now the challenge
I'm getting is
um you know how you gonna actually set
up that labor majority government what
are you going to do in government I'm
pleased to take that we did make
progress here in the east of England we
did make progress in the places you
mentioned but we've got to do more and
I've said to my shadow cabinet we've got
step up again the trajectory we're on is
a trajectory that takes us to a majority
labor government and I'm very pleased
about that and that's not just about
numbers if you look I mean we're talking
today about the NHS but if you look
across the country the sort of
overwhelming conclusion pretty well now
is almost everything is broken and
nobody feels better off now than they
did 13 years ago that is the scale of
the challenge and we need a majority
labor government to get there that means
we've got to earn every vote including
in the east of England including in the
places that you mentioned I'm determined
that we will continue to do that but the
the progression in the labor party from
where we started to where we are has
been very very significant and most
people when I took over as leader-led
party shook me by the hand and said good
luck and then an ex-breath said it's not
possible to get from where you are to a
labor government in one parliamentary
term I've never accepted that I don't
accept it now and we will march to go
back to my opening words on here in
Braintree and the east of England as we
will across the whole of the United
Kingdom thank you all very much indeed
thank you thank you